this episode of real engineering is
brought to you by brilliant a problem
solving website that teaches you to
think like an engineer if we were to
define World War 2 in just one
technology the likely winner would be
aerial bombing World War one revolved
around stagnant and debilitating trench
warfare the both sides sought to avoid
in future tanks and planes arose as a
way of breaking enemy lines quickly and
inflict damage the rate of technological
progress for delivering larger and more
accurate bombs during World War two was
astronomical but early in the war the
technology was still in its infancy
the Germans relied heavily on the Stuka
dive-bomber a short-range bomber whose
siren became a harbinger of death on the
battlefield it dived towards its target
planting it firmly in its crosshairs in
parroting its bomb with the velocity it
needed to fly straight to the target
before releasing and pulling up higher
to avoid a collision with the ground
this procedure was so taxing on its
pilot that the Germans developed an
automatic die flap that would deploy
even if the pilot had knocked themselves
unconscious with g-force these tactics
arose because bombing aiming technology
was so primitive bomb sites were
rudimentary and required skilled
operators having to factor in not only
the speed and altitude of the aircraft
but the terminal velocity of the bomb
and how it would be affected by wind as
it fell bombing from high altitude where
the Bombers would be relatively safe
from flak gave little precision to
target specific buildings this combined
with poor navigation equipment resulted
in both sides devolving into carpet
bombing causing massive civilian losses
which did little to help either side win
a war we saw in a previous episode how
much effort Nazi cities put into
anti-aircraft defences and similar
efforts were made in Britain these
tactics did not come cheap losses were
high for both sites Barnes Wallis an
aeronautical engineer at Vickers
saw the futility in these tactics and
set his focus on developing new
technologies to aid British bombers in
destroying strategic German positions
this was nothing new factories oil
storage and transportation
infrastructure were always primary
targets but Burns wanted to create a
weapon capable of destroying a target
others deemed invulnerable dams dams
posed a tantalizing target they supply
hydro
you provide water for industry and the
German population and the resulting
deluge of water from the massive
reservoirs would cause damage much
greater than any bomb the Brits had at
their disposal the Germans were not
ignorant to the allure of the dams as a
bombing target attacks on dams had
happened earlier in the war like the one
on the massive italian terzo dam in
sardinia which held back europe's
largest man-made lake and provided the
italian island with 1/3 of its
electricity they attempted the raid in
broad daylight with 8 swordfish flow
planes 3 simply failed to find the
target due to terrible weather and the
rest were welcomed with anti-aircraft
fire taking one of the planes down the
remaining four continue to the target
and dropped her P dose which traveled
under water to their target before
exploding but the dam remained standing
the bombs were simply not powerful
enough to blast through the heavy
concrete of the dam to make matters
worse all dams across Europe would be
protected by anti-torpedo netting from
this point on so a new method to deliver
an enormous bomb capable of taking down
a structure this strong was needed
Wallace spent most of his time devising
devices to take on this challenge and
took several things into consideration
when designing his bombs explosive
pressures decay extremely quickly and
thus to ensure damage to the structure
it must be as close as possible pressure
waves propagate through denser mediums
far more efficiently and thus explosions
underground or in water will be more
powerful and finally doubling the size
of the bomb does not result in twice the
blast radius to increase the blast
radius drastically would require a
drastically larger bomb his design ethos
from here was simple designed the
biggest bomb his planes could carry and
have them detonate underground or in
water to maximize her effect even
further he presented his ideas in a 1941
paper and note on the method of
attacking Axis powers with the primary
focus on a tent on earth penetrating
bomb that would be dropped from 40,000
feet this was the most powerful
non-nuclear bomb ever used until just
last year and 42 were dropped in the
final year of the war that helped cut
German supplies to the frontline by
destroying via docks and railways and
put Wallis is remembered for a different
bomb the British government hired the
Road Research Laboratory
civil engineering firm to begin
experiments to find the smallest charge
needed to destroy the Munna dam they
constructed several scale model dams and
used abandoned dams in Wales to find
their answer they found that a 10 ton
bomb exploding 50 feet from the dam
would not destroy us but a 2 ton bomb
could do the job if it was placed
directly next to the face of the dam
with torpedo netting installed this job
required precision that had not been
seen before and the method that was
supposed would break all convention
burns decided the best course of action
was to create a skipping bomb that would
bounce over the protective netting
before sinking next to the dam and
exploding he concluded that the mines
would have to impact at less than 7
degrees in order to skip and all
subsequent bounces would have to be
below 7 degrees to ensure the bomb
continued until momentum was lost the
bomb would be given backspin prior to
release in order to take advantage of
the Magnus effect which is left created
by his spinning body spinning the bomb
provided stability like a bicycle wheel
and motion helping the bomb remain on a
straight trajectory but the lift the
spinning provided was far more useful by
adding lift the bombs trajectory gained
more horizontal motion and its angle of
impact was reduced both of which aid
skipping and allow the bomber to release
the bomb sooner giving them additional
time to escape the imminent explosion
once submerged the remaining spin would
help push the bomb fort ensuring it
stayed in close contact to the dam wall
this wholly unconventional bomb posed
some design challenges any spinning
object needs to be precisely balanced to
prevent vibrations that could
potentially break it or interfere with
its operation to aid this burns early
spherical designs were scrapped in
favour of a drum which could be more
easily manufactured and balanced while
also aiding in its release mechanism the
bombs were fitted to Avro Lancaster's
which were modified to accommodate the
bomb the bomb doors were removed to fit
the bomb which would protrude below the
plane for the duration of the flight the
lower ventral guns were removed to
reduce drag as the mission would be
flown so low to the ground that they
would provide no protection against
fighters to v-shaped mounting erics were
then attached with free spinning disk
mounts which would mate with the support
rings on either side of the bomb an
off-the-shelf motor typically used to
power hydraulic pumps that submarines
was used and connected to the bomb with
a pulley finally to release the bomb
burns needed a way of on mating the bomb
from its spinning mount this was done
rather ingenious Lee these mounting arms
were stabilized to a tension wire which
kept them firmly mated with the bomb
when the bomb needed to be released the
tension was released with a solenoid
actuated grip compressed springs would
then force the arms to swing outwards by
just a couple of degrees enough to
release the bomb the bomb was now ready
but little time was afforded to the crew
that would man the plane that would
carry them a new special squadron was
created specifically for this mission
formed with some of the most experienced
pilots the RAF had to offer and this
experience would be needed as the entire
mission would be flown at extremely low
altitude at night navigators had to
learn to navigate with limited
information often little more than the
bomb-aimer is calling out landmarks they
passed over to increase the time they
had to train their Lancaster's were
fitted with blue plastic screens to the
windows to limit visibility and light
during the day after many test drops the
crew were finally informed of their
target on the morning of the attack on
May 16th that night they would take off
from RAF Compton in three waves with a
total of 19 aircraft little would go
smoothly from here the first of the
planes was lost just an hour into the
mission when it strayed off course over
the heavily defended Texel island off
the northern coast of the Netherlands
two planes collided with power lines and
cables as they flew low over the Dutch
and German countryside another plane
flew solo as across the North Sea that
the low-slung bomb collided with a wave
dislodging it and forcing its crew to
return to base followed shortly after by
another plane badly damaged by flak at
this point the entire first wave of
planes had failed their mission but
others were finally reaching their
target Gibson the commander of the
squadron was the first to arrive flying
at 370 km/h just 60 feet from the water
he successfully dropped his bomb which
bounced three times before sinking and
exploding sending a gigantic spout of
water over the dam but it had sunk too
short of the time on the following run a
bomb bounced over the dam and destroyed
the powerhouse at its base while the
Lancaster the carry that crashed into
flames after being struck by flack
Gibson and his point circled back around
to act as a decoy for Henri Young whose
bomb veered off towards the banks of the
reservoir on the fourth try the squadron
finally got a direct hit
but another blow was needed to collapse
the dam which came shortly after as
Gibson and Mickey Martin flew decoy runs
alongside multiple who scored a direct
hit on the already crumbling town
sending 330 million tons of water into
the valleys below with their first
target down the first wave continued
onto either down with three bombs left
which was all they needed after two
unsuccessful attempts where one bomb
damaged the plane that was dropping it
night's Lancaster came in at the perfect
speed and altitude releasing his bomb
before quickly pulling hard to avoid the
300-foot hill directly behind the dam
the first wave were now out of bombs had
made their journey home but this leg was
just as dangerous as the already damaged
plane was shut down soon after and two
more Lancaster's would be brought down
by flak on the return leg the third wave
lost two planes before reaching their
newly assigned target one strayed over
the city of ham and was gunned down by
anti-aircraft guns another was lost over
the Netherlands what remained mounted an
unsuccessful attack on the SARP Dam
before returning to base in all the
British lost eight Lancaster's in the
rate killing 53 men while another three
who managed to survive their crashes
were taken prisoner but the damage
inflicted on the Germans was far greater
the resulting floods wreaked havoc on
the RORO Valley every bridge downstream
445 kilometers was destroyed 10
factories were destroyed and a further
100 damaged mines were flooded and an
estimated 400,000 tons of coal
production was lost acres of farmland
were wiped out and over 1500 people died
in the resulting floods all this damage
with just 19 aircraft this was precision
that had not been seen before however
some have questioned whether the raids
were worth the loss of life many of the
people killed in the floods were
prisoners of war in forced labour and
others are quick to dismiss this
as a failure because the Germans
recovered so quickly taking just five
months to repair the dams in time to
ensure the reservoirs would fill for the
following summer but these people seem
to ignore the immense amount of
resources that had to be diverted to
repair the dance
they were repaired quickly precisely
because they were so vital to the German
war effort thought it was worth shifting
thousands of workers and materials away
from the frontlines d-day which would
come just a year after this raid could
have gone very differently if those
resources had instead gone to fortify
the beaches of France even further these
19 bombers pound-for-pound did more
damage to the German war effort than any
other British air raid thanks to the
precision they had been engineered to
achieve and precision would become the
focus of money of the war's greatest
engineers once the war had ended after
all the moon was much further away than
any previous target once again for this
kind of topic a smooth segue isn't
appropriate but videos like this would
not be possible without brilliant my
goal for this project has always been to
inspire the next generation of engineers
brilliant is the perfect partner for
this channel because their courses are
designed to educate you from knowing
nothing to having a deep understanding
of the topic perhaps you feel you could
brush up on your statistics skills a
valuable analytic tool that could help
you academically and in your everyday
life this course on statistics guides
you through problems that are broken
into digestible sections with fun
problems to test your knowledge along
the way this is just one of many courses
on brilliant with more courses due to be
released soon on things like automotive
engineering and Python coding if you've
been inspired and you want to educate
yourself then go to brilliant org ford
slash real engineering and sign up for
free the first 73 people to go to that
link will get 20% off their annual
premium subscription as always thanks
for watching and thank you to all my
patreon supporters if you'd like to see
more from me the links to my Instagram
Twitter subreddit and discord server are
below